What I want to do is go back to my terminal.
Instead of looking at a GCC bug, we're going to look at an LVM bug.
I believe this is one we already looked at a little bit.
We say clang -02 small.c.
It's going to die with an assertion violation about isa(Val)
and Unknown live-in to the entry block, and that's assertion failed.
What we need to do first is check of the lvm people already know about this one.
We're going to go here to their bugzilla and search for this exact string.
All right. They don't know about this bug, so that's nice.
If we know about a bug and they don't know about it, we can report it.
Now we have to go back and make a reduced test case.
What I'm going to do here is instead of invoking the delta debugger,
which is this nice extremely general purpose powerful tool,
I'm going to invoke a different tool that's called C reduce,
and it's one produced by my group.
What it is is an extremely special-purposed delta debugger,
so it operates on exactly the same delta debugging ideas that the other tool
operates by, and it just has extra knowledge embedded in it
about how to reduce C programs.
This is going to take a little while, so you don't have to wait for it like I do.
Let's run a time command and just see how long it takes.
That took about 11 minutes. Not incredibly quick, but not too shabby either.
Remember, this wasn't time that I had to be attending to the computer.
The computer was just doing an automated search algorithm.
Here is the output of the reduced test case.
It's pretty small, so let's check its byte count.
It has 274 bytes. That's nice.
What I'm going to do here is make a bug report.
What I'm going to first do is make sure we know the version of clang.
It's version 156970.
I'm going to make sure the test case gets included.
I'm going to show clang crashing on it. That's a bug report.
If I haven't appeared to go through all of the steps that I've narrated to you earlier,
it's because I've reported a lot of compiler bugs, and I know what I can get away with.
There we go.
This includes, I believe, enough information for the LVM people to reproduce the bug.
It should be good.
I've marked that we're reporting its chunk.
We just need a name for this bug report.
The bugzilla is trying to help us avoid a duplicate,
and I don't think it's told us about anything that we didn't know.
In fact, all these are marked as fixed anyway, so we're good. Now let us ship this off.
Now the LVM developers, when they get up in the morning,
have a new bug report to look at.
That concludes our data on bug reporting.